the josh duggar child pornography case
is officially closed on wednesday josh
was sentenced to 151 months in prison
and that's nearly 13 years behind bars
today it's my honor and privilege to
join in this announcement of a guilty
verdict in the case of united states
versus josh duggar that was just five
months ago after the judge reached a
verdict the 34 year old was found guilty
on two counts of receiving and
possessing child porn we respect the
jury's verdict and we look forward to
continuing this fight on appeal we have
no more comment at this time
according to court docs obtained by et
at the time josh's lawyers requested a
sentence of 60 months the former reality
star was originally facing up to 20
years in prison with fines up to 250 000
per count and josh's fate affects his
entire family
god's grace can give me the strength to
love josh
when
others would say he doesn't deserve it
prior to josh's conviction his wife anna
spoke to his character in a letter to
the judge obtained by e.t anna wrote in
part consider reuniting us as a family
again soon he is a kind loving
supportive and caring father and husband
his primary focus in life when your
world is shattered
there are a lot of emotions
that you have to walk through
josh's legal trouble started in 2015
after the 19 kids and counting star was
accused of molesting a babysitter and
four of his sisters
josh's parents were in complete
disbelief when they sat down with megyn
kelly we were shocked i mean we were
just devastated i don't think any parent
is prepared for trauma like that i think
as parents you feel like a failure when
one of your kids does something wrong
and while josh's parents and siblings
made appearances in court throughout the
trial his sister jill and brother-in-law
derek shared their feelings about it
publicly after josh's guilty verdict was
announced the couple wrote on their
website nobody is above the law our
hearts go out to the victims of child
abuse or any kind of exploitation